breaking news on the libby squire murder
trial and pavel relevic has been found
guilty at sheffield crown court
of raping and murdering the hull
university student
libby squire sky's katarina vitozi is
live outside
sheffield crown court for us katarina
yes just in the last few minutes the
jury which has been deliberating for
five
days now coming back uh with guilty
verdicts for both
counts of murder and rape against
libby squires the 21 year old whole
university student
who went missing after a night out with
friends in january
january 31st 2019
uh two years later now a man found
guilty
of her rape and murder pavel relivitch a
26 year old butcher from hull
uh the most tragic of circumstances and
libby squire's family have been
attending court throughout this process
very disturbing descriptions of what
happened to her that night
bertrelovich and his defense team
throughout saying
that although he did admit to having sex
with the university student he said that
was consensual but a jury now
deciding that in fact it was rape and
that he then was guilty of her murder my
colleague gerard tubb has this report
libby squire was raped and murdered by a
serial sex offender her killer was
parvel relevic
who'd been preying on students near the
university of hull
for 18 months his offending was so
brazen
the police were able to find him on cctv
performing a sex act in the road but
despite committing at least
nine offenses in a small area the
students he was targeting
were never warned someone was prowling
these streets
in 2017 relevant broke into this
student's bedroom and stole sex toys
a brief police investigation got nowhere
victims words in this report are spoken
by actors
i just got a call to say that there'd be
no fingerprint match
there would be no other leads or
evidence so it was kind of closed
because they didn't know who'd done it
by the time libby was caught on cctv on
the night she disappeared
relevant had committed at least six more
offenses
he can be seen stalking libby who was
drunk
in distress and probably hypothermic
within minutes she was in his car
after extensive police searches it was
almost
seven weeks before libby's body was
found in the river humber
now the charity end violence against
women is calling for an investigation
we'd like to see that the the police
inspectorate um take this seriously
and launch an investigation into what's
happened here is that we can
learn the lessons um from this case and
be sure that we are joining the dots of
lower level offences
of a sexual nature because it's so
tragic
that often sexual predators can escalate
their behavior
this victim of relevitch's voyeurism has
told us
she feels let down maybe if we'd known
we would have taken it more seriously
we would have made sure that we were
going out in groups that we were being
aware of our surroundings
that we were looking out for each other
more in a statement
humberside police said we're satisfied
that we did carry out proportionate
investigations into these reports at the
time
and that they were treated with the
appropriate level of seriousness
it went on there was no clear pattern of
offending
that could reasonably have been detected
at the time
libby squire's killer will be sentenced
later
gerard tub sky news hull